Lords of the Fallen is clearly inspired
by Dark Souls but it's important not to
get bogged down by too many comparisons
between the souls games and this one
Lords of the Fallen is distinct enough
to earn its own spotlight and perhaps to
earn your love as well this is an
entertaining and Atmospheric adventure
and one that deserves a sequel that
further flushes out its fantasy world
world might be too generous a word
actually you spend most of your time in
corridors and moody combat arenas not
gazing on two massive landscapes you
roam from a third-person perspective
swinging an axe or sword dodging or
blocking incoming attacks and
occasionally spewing out some magic an
energy meter depletes when you roll an
attack forcing you to manage your
defenses so you aren't vulnerable to
damage different melee weapons require
different approaches but Lords of the
Fallen gives each of them an authentic
sense of weight it takes time to swing
that humongous great sword you carry and
improper timing leaves you open to
counter-attacks
you also have spells to cast in a
gauntlet that shoots out magic
projectiles among other attacks casting
the limited spells you can choose from
when leveling up and switching between
those spells is a matter of pressing or
holding a button there's no need to
switch from a dagger to a wand if you
want to produce a speeding figure that
runs right through your enemies for a
good amount of damage there are no bows
and arrows and Lords of the Fallen it's
all swords and sorcery
you
the game insists on trying to tell story
but the early hours are pretty
incoherent and antihero Harkin doesn't
have much interesting to say anyway
instead it's better to let the frozen
walkways and imposing monastery speak
for themselves
this place seeks to murder you consider
the titles of the bosses you fight beast
champion Annihilator they have one
purpose to kill to call Lords of the
Fallen up for man's Dark Souls sells it
too short for one Lords of the Fallen
strikes a different kind of tone its
Moody and oppressive but rarely
terrifying it is a power fantasy not a
death simulator and the chunky ornate
art style reflects the difference Lords
of the Fallen has a few challenges but
it's rare for you to feel frail or
afraid the game simply isn't hard enough
to make your blood boil that's at least
true in the main world the visits you
make to a shadowy and sinister
Otherworld are a little more frightening
traversing this dark dimension is like
exploring a foggy desert at midnight you
can barely see further than the tip of
your blade your steps into the beyond
first lead you just simple Knights and
ghouls which require only that you put
the clumsy targeting system to good use
soon however you could encounter our
rolling fire demon that puts up a bit
more fight you reach this realm by
entering portals that only unlock and
you've killed some unknown beasts hoping
to find some special treasure like a new
hammer or a rune for upgrading your
equipment you die but not frequently
enough for Lords of the Fallen to get
grindy or frustrating when you perish
you leave behind your ghost and revive
at whichever Ruby crystal you last saved
at your ghost contains all the
experience you've accumulated since the
prior death but it doesn't remain
forever so it's in your best interests
to go retrieve it at least early on
every fallen enemy will have respawned
after your death but you'll at least be
armed with the knowledge of
what lies ahead of you death is not a
huge setback though experience can be
regained easily and in the last several
hours you earn too little experience
from killing enemies to mind the loss
the bosses may have ominous titles but
if you have souls experience you can off
most of them on the first attempt the
challenge ramps up nicely during the
lead-up to the final showdown however in
a few bosses particularly the final one
demand a bit of extra thinking the
greatest challenge Lords of the Fallen
provides isn't a welcome one it's easy
to lose yourself in the crypts and
corridors unsure of where the game means
for you to go every region cleverly
connects with others but some areas are
so same ish and some entrance is so
subtle that the game can become aimless
the annoyances are few however you could
call Lords of the fall in a souls game
for the meek at 20 hours the first time
through it's not as long as the games
that inspired it nor is it as special as
hard or as mysterious but Lords of the
Fallen has a consistency of tone a
powerful spirit weighty combat and a
beautiful world to explore and it's one
of the biggest pleasant surprises 2014
you